Nouvelle vidéo de gaming,
entre mecs,
entre couilles,
100 % testostérone,
FAUX. Ouais !
[ bruits de tirs et d'explosions ]
On est avec Marion qui est vraiment une gameuse
hardcore on peut le dire qui fait partie de la team
millenium qui est la plus grosse team je crois de France
Marion : L' une des plus grosses team
Alors là on joue a Doom, t'avais joué au premier
Opus en 93 ?
Nan, là tu m'défonce un peu là en fait Ok d'accord *rire*
Marion : Nan j'rigole
Attends j'suis en train de voir que tu vises vraiment entre
les deux yeux, la meuf elle est d'une précision totale, c'est abusé
T'es plus PC ou plus console ?
PC
Ben ça s'voit
*rire*
La meuf elle est totalement à l'aise même sur une
manette
Donc on est avec Sissy Mua
C'est ça ton blase.
Est ce qu'on peut t'appeler par ton prénom ?
Nan. D'accord ça met tout de suite l'ambiance.
[rire]
On peut commencer le gaming.
Non mais parce que je sais pas comment on joue en fait.
Je passe la manette, elle est comme ça
Le mec qui tient une manette comme ça
tu sais d'avance que ça va pas être un gros gameur, c'est sûr et certain.
Ouais c'est ça !
On est avec Sunsup
Mais on peut t'appeler Jade.
On peut m'appeler Jade pour les intimes.
Ou Gérard...
Alors il faut rappeler que t'es une youtubeuse gaming
mais tu fais pas de gaming fps
Ça se voit absolument pas que je suis une youtubeuse gaming
parce que vu que...
Bah vu que t'es dans la première pièce depuis un quart d'heure, oui.
Ça me donne envie de faire du gaming.
Bah en fait, il n'y avait pas assez de filles qui faisaient du gaming
Et j'avais trop envie d'en faire
Au début j'avais peur tu sais
parce que ça fait un peu...
Mais tu jouais déjà ?
Oui, oui je jouais en dehors.
Puis j'ai commencé à jouer à pleins de petits jeux heuu...
en me disant que ça serait cool de...
Ils vont me sauter à la tronche !
Bah ça va, tu te débrouilles pas mal là !
Et ouais !
Alors on est dans une session gaming avec Horia, bonjour Horia.
Salut !
C'est quoi l'origine de ce prénom ?
Algérien.
Merde !
Alors en fait, pendant que tu me parles, et que tu me racontes tes origines
Yes !
Je suis en train de me faire déglinguer en fait.
Alors comme on est dans un gaming avec, mon but c'est pas de jouer tout seul
c'est que tu vas jouer à ma place et précisément maintenant quand tout le monde m'attaque.
Nan, nan, nan !
Ahh !
Ah ouais d'accord donc là on est vraiment dans un...
On peut pas aller camper ? C'est pas ça qu'on dit ?
Nan mais on est pas au camping.
On est avec Morgane Cakes Paradise
Ouais c'est ça.
Donc t'as une chaine de cuisine
C'est ça de cooking oui.
C'est quoi le... le plat que tu ne sais pas faire ?
Je suis pas trop salé, je ne fais que du sucré.
Mais je ne mange que du salé mais je ne fais que du sucré.
Ce qui est vachement pratique heuu...
C'est tout à fait pratique !
On est avec Sananas, salut !
Salut !
Donc t'es youtubeuse beauté ?
Oui.
Est-ce que tu pourrais me donner des petits conseils de beauté par exemple ?
Pour tes cheveux ?
Pourquoi tu vises mes cheveux en particulier, je ne comprends pas.
Mais tes cheveux c'est voulu comme ça les petites bouclettes ou heuu?
Ce n'est malheureusement pas voulu... Je suis né comme ça.
Mais nan mais avant t'avais les cheveux plus courts.
Si jamais tu devais me donner des petits conseils beauté ça serait quoi par exemple ?
Ça dépend si tu te maquilles ou pas.
Est-ce qu'il y a des mecs qui mettent de l'anti-therme, est-ce que toi c'est pareil.
On est avec Lucie Decosse, comme son accoutrement laisse à penser : championne de tennis.
Quoi ? -Ouais...
T'aime bien le gaming ? -Je suis pas une pro
Ça s'appelle Doom, c'est un jeu qui est sorti en 93, il y a eu plusieurs opus et la c'est le tout dernier
Ok la on joue en exclu.